[Music]
Runk oh here we go crystal.com for the
new special uh I'll talk a little bit
about that later on in the episode about
how my experience has been releasing it
but crystal.com uh for my special it is
out now go to the website and get it now
or hit the link below uh and I will be
in Fort Meyers and also Orlando and also
Baltimore and also somewhere in uh
Virginia Richmond and then somewhere in
somewhere else Trenton so go to chia.com
for tickets uh just go to chia.com
honestly spend some time on it have a
great great time uh but other than that
here comes the new and
improved
[Music]
congratulations
congratulations how about that players
and play ATS how about that play
look at this and play
it check it out dude what the we're it's
I wanted it more of a log cabin Vibe so
we could share ideas so we could hang
out but welcome to the new
studio um it's reminiscent of the old
Studio originally we wanted to get back
to our uh
Roots um but check it out man check it
out check it out and stuff it's awesome
right look at that um and none other
than n my wife did this and that awesome
no we got this professionally done it
took three weeks the guys came in here
and worked from 400 a.m. to noon uh why
do but because they no what I want I
know I've talked about this before but
people who do remodeling get here they
work too early on in the morning and
then they're off by noon and that
absolutely pisses me off but my wife did
this and she did it in one or two days
um and it was great because boy does she
just hit the ground running with that
she just goes you want a new you want a
new do redo the thing I say yeah
maybe go upstairs come back downstairs
half of it is already done and I say I
didn't really say yes but this looks
actually amazing uh I don't have the eye
for that dude some people have eyes for
that you know they look at [__] it's
like Minority Report and they're like if
I put this here and that like this and
then my mom does that my mom has my mom
dude it's the home of 10,000
chachis sounds like a horror movie that
Rob Zombie directed the home of 10,000
chachis directed by Ellie deia it's just
a among clapping monkey over over a
fireplace and some and some uh spider
plants the home of 10,000 chachis what
did uh uh Rob Zombie do 10,000 corpses
or something it's too many corpses 1,000
that's not that's not tooo much that's
just just less than 10,000 uh home of a
thousand uh no something a thousand it
doesn't matter um it's been out for 90
years uh so but yeah so uh this is what
she did look at that this is all fan
stuff this is all fan stuff except for
this this was given to me by Ivan get
rid of and uh and all the rest of the
stuff is fan stuff have a good silly
good time says Dr Phil Marco
um junle V Dam and Tupac and then Blanca
throwback to my uh encourageable special
speaking of specials my special is out
on chia.com grow or die dude it has been
really wild man having this and doing
this myself shout out to like the fact
that we can do this now as artists you
can take the reins and steer the ship
the way you want to steer it to right
now take it from me I've done both I've
done both I've done with the streaming
services I've done on network TV I've
done dude when you make your own channel
Unstoppable dude and it's
beautiful and the streaming and the
download is
going it's going great Bonkers it's
going great dude and I couldn't be
happier and I hope you enjoyed if you
haven't seen the special yet go to chrys
lea.com and get it and um also like on a
serious note thank you thank you for
doing that I really really like can't
even you know people say corny stuff
like oh I can't find the words and all
that stuff and it just you know it's
like there are words for everything you
know like you can figure out the words
to say it so what I'm trying to say is I
won't say there there are no words but I
will say I'm too dumb to actually find
the words and construct the sentence to
express my gratitude because I mean it
man just for the we're filming this two
days after the special came out guy
stopped me on the street and he was like
dude the special and and I go like this
and it was about 6 seconds until he said
the next word and I was like I don't
know how this is going to go he goes the
special and I I just stood there like a
dumb dumb because these days people will
say
anything and I I waited I was in the
parking lot and then I finally went like
this and he says it's Fire Man it is so
good I mean they're all good this one uh
he said uh I just thank you thank you he
said and dude and I went in my car and I
sat there for a little bit like I was in
a movie and I just had a a little bit of
a moment so anyway dude whatever I'm
trying to express my gratitude but I'm
too dumb to have the words to say it and
construct a sentence so I appre pre pre
all you um cy.com anyway uh I'm good I'm
feeling good I'm I'm having a good time
haven't worn the shirt
in over a year decided to put it on just
throw it
on and uh you know give it a give it a
whirl again dude how about how it is
when you find a shirt that you used to
wear and you go
huh what a you're so dumb dude when
you're going through your closet you go
oh yeah that one and you go huh and you
throw it on you're like huh and then you
walk outside and you feel good and
you're just like huh all right huh and
nobody notices but you you know but
you're just like yeah that's the weird
thing about fashion right it's a weird
thing about fashion because I was I was
watching uh I was at the gym earlier and
I was
watching uh a uh my buddy Steve hoe uh
who was on Shameless right he was at the
gym we didn't go together but I saw him
there and I was like I wonder if we're
going to say hi you ever go to the gym
you see somebody like I wonder if I'm
going to say hi that guy like guy I
don't know and in my head I'm like oh
maybe people everyone hates me so so he
probably hates me by now you know I've
known him for 6 years I think the
trajectory is he hates me by now and um
so I'm just working out you know how I
do it I was doing all sorts of leg stuff
and um and he's
just the next Batman I mean this guy's
he looks great he looks awesome and he's
beefed up he's yoked and I'm jealous and
it's all good dude he's also like two
inches taller than me the guy's a giant
he's a good looking dude whatever anyway
he's doing these workouts and he's
grunting and he's doing it good and he's
all sweaty and I'm looking at him and
I'm like godamn
dude and I go and I say and I'm like
chicks probably love that [__] just he's
all sweaty and his his hair's in his
face I'm like my wife probably thinks
he's hot he's all big and tall and it
doesn't even matter what he's [__]
wearing you know like chicks are always
like at the gym and they're like oh my
God I'm a mess oh I can't even believe I
got hit on at the gym because I'm in a
mess and I had a hat on and I just women
think that if they wear a hat that their
tits go away you know what I mean
oh you think that's because you didn't
put on makeup that you plush lips went
away oh my God and I look so ugly in the
meantime
dude you know and so um I'm looking at
him and I'm like man that's it's kind of
unfair that dudes just don't have to do
uh [__] which goes back to what I'm
talking about putting on my own uh my
new shirt I'm like nobody I feel better
looking but nobody thinks that it's all
in your head so the key is to always
think to get to that level of dude I am
looking fantastic but you can't though
can you CU when you wake up your face is
Puffy cuz when you wake up your hair is
absolutely terrible and when you wake up
and you look in the mirror you're
looking a little flabby hey you can't
get away from it dude just don't look at
yourself
honestly but then you start looking
really [__] stupid right because cuz
you're
like anyway I worked out harder after I
saw him and we did say hi and he's a
nice guy and doesn't hate me so it's all
good then I went and I got like a Cuda I
got a um protein or no a a stupid shake
that was at uh this spot this grocery
store this high-end grocery store and um
I went in and I got it and it's called
Uh the post dude I'm such an idiot I was
looking at the things and it said
postwork like which one am I going to
get oh yeah postwork I get the post
workout I just worked out so that's the
one I got to get you know like let me
get the which one you want a
post-workout you how how stupid I felt I
was all sweaty you know just came from
the gym yeah let me get the post-workout
like and and the guy was just doing the
cash register was like I got him you
know ah they got him we got them we got
them oh I don't like that's the the
thing when they're like we or behind the
counter they're like um I got um let's
see here's what I got I got brussel
sprout bacon dude you don't have [__]
man the people came early in the morning
and put the stuff here you just came
here and started giving it out you don't
have [__] but he did
it so he had he gave me the the the
post-workout
Shake dude $15 hey is it Thanksgiving
dinner hey what's in
it hey what's in it did you sprinkle
gold buan in it what's buan
[Laughter]
dude what is that what's in it elephant
tusks hey
hm yeah it's got doto Bird's F webbed
feet grinded up in it dude I want to
know
what that is crazy a $15 uh Shake I got
it took 25 minutes to make man nobody
was in line and I'm sitting there
sweating and my wife is like where are
you cuz I have to be here for
stuff anyway life is tough dude it
really is it's hard when you have to
wait that long for a [__] post rout
shake so anyway after that I hopped in
my Ferrari and came home dude
um it's
uh I don't give a [__] bro I'm unhinged
man I'm freaking
unhinged the mind of a Madman you know
I'm so happy I don't care man I'm so
happy dude I have two kids and my life's
beautiful my babies my life's beautiful
life's beautiful what's that [__]
thing
Sensational dude Future's hot um like
sexy
um anyway dude let's [__] check and
see what we have I I I absolutely
um adore you guys today I feel like I
took a [__] dude did somebody put
weed in my
coffee babe did you put weed in my
[__] post-workout Shake
bro I want to be this I want to be th
this is how proud I am okay I'm very
proud to be married to my wife but when
but later on in life that's my wife to
be that old that's your
wife so proud amazing dude oh wow that's
amazing that's my wife that's your
wife so proud she's drinking wine out of
the bottle wow that's amazing that's my
wife that's my wife your dude there you
go the most proud person and he's
[__] 60 love
it
um I uh this is hold on I want to see
this theft of two million
dimes two two million dimes from
truckload it's just to to 2 million
chicks with bikinis on um of coins from
the US mint leaves four facing federal
charges bro how about
this I'm like we don't ever sit and
think about this but let me just like
actually take this home okay listen to
me right now what I'm about to
say people do
heists you know what I'm saying like
people
do heists they're heisting out there
like they actually are like at a point
in their lives where they go
imagine getting to a point where you
could be like I I guess I could rob a
bank and then
thinking I bet I have some friends that
would do it with me are you [__] me
why are the most hardcore criminals the
most loyal [__] you know what
I'm talking about dude I could yo I'm
down for you to rob a
bank who the [__] would I rob a bank
with I would you know what dude if I had
to rob a bank I'd have to do it myself
there's no way I think maybe my wife
would do it with me and Billy but not
Calvin he's too scared you know Billy
doesn't really know what's going on
yet give me all your [__] all right
dude everybody give me all your money
and nobody gets hurt sweetie can you
hold him for a sec here hold it yeah he
spitting up you know what hold on one
second baby hold the gun here hey buddy
come here here I'll hold it shh baby shh
[__] godamn it I can't do this [__]
without arguing um everybody on the
floor stay on the floor just because we
weren't looking at you and we started
having our own [__] doesn't mean you
shouldn't be staying on the floor don't
hit she hit the button we got to go babe
she hit the button she hit the secret
button um baby we got to go go go what
do you mean I'm driving move over but
you drive bad not when it
counts we remember when we had the
conversation in the car when we said you
were the better driver but if we had to
get [__] if we had to get away it would
be
me
move over come on here we
go it's the [__] low proo tires God
damn
it freeze it's just that
I cl cl cling all the
coins oh dude good SE good good thing
the seats are already red
oh uh
um Philadelphia God imagine being in
Philadelphia and just like I'll be in
Philadelphia by there by the way reading
in Philadelphia Christ lea.com I'll be
there soon imagine growing up in
Philadelphia and just being like so
[__] obsessed with the Eagles and
[__] you know and just proud when they
win you
know oh dude the city I would hate to be
in Cleveland the the week after they win
the Super Bowl whenever that is God how
annoying would that be when I went to
Pittsburgh you can't look anywhere
without seeing a Steeler sign you go to
sleep and you're
like is that a still sign on the inside
of my
Outlets Philadelphia Federal authorities
have released more details and unsealed
charges in the theft of more than two
million dimes dimes like actual coin
dimes dimes bro that's like $10
million no $20 million the other
it's
$200,000 oh that's not worth it also so
heavy we need so here's what we're going
to do two M dude my optimistic ass was
like that's $20
million two million Dives is the other
way
dude imagine being like we're gonna dude
they should make that move oh are you
[__] me dude if they made that movie
and we're going to rob them in
dimes is what we're going to do first of
all we need 600
guys why do we need so many mate they're
so [__] heavy have you tried to carry
[__] 300 dimes you can't mate you
might think you can but you can't we got
to work out for [__] two years all of
us six we need 600 memberships to the
gym we [__] need them for two years
and then we're going to go rob two
million dim we need 600 no we need eight
oh we need [__] 2,000 people is what
we
need freeze this is a robbery just so
many dudes in the [__] back it's so
150 guys got caught but you know
what dude two times earlier this year
from a tractor trailer okay from a
tractor trailer that had picked up the
coins from US Mint in Philadelphia dude
imagine you're like dude let's get this
vent let's get this [__] van Here We
Go There It Is freeze and then it's just
full of dimonds oh for [__] sake dude
that would be my wife you we got the
dimes one babe great I knew we should
have got the other one but you wanted to
follow the other one I said it was
driving
clunky I said it was driving clunky when
it went over the [__] potholes what
did it look like what did it look like
it looked
like lizo and and one of the people from
The View were [__] that's how how
much it looked like it was in
there the truck driver was bound for
Miami when he pulled into a parking lot
to sleep on April 13th during the night
thieves made off with a portion of its
cargo of
750,000 in dimes a shipment weighing
about six tons I was right dude how do
you [__] where do you put it
thousands of coin were left scattered
all over the lot in Northeast
Philadelphia look at this
dude
two
100,000 234,00 in stolen
dimes where do you put it after that
all right is what we're going to do
we're going we'll get [__] 2 million
dimes we need 2,000 people to help us
with this house we're going to rush into
the [__] bank all right and then
after that here's what we're going to do
we're going to deposit them but we
probably have to do it
like I don't know
$200 at a time otherwise people will
think like it's fishy you know
especially if like they know a lot of
Dimes are listen right so here what
we're going to do we're going to take
flights to other areas it's the most
expensive Heist to be honest we've got
to pay everyone [__] get the tickets to
go somewhere else ah [__] honestly we're
going to be in a hole after
this the plane flights to all the
different [__] States and [__] God
damn it we're we're too deep we're too
deep we can't back out
now
um detective said at the time the
surveillance video showed six men
dressed in gry hoodies who the [__] were
they Transformers how do you carry six
tons did you know who the guys are too
imagine the big ass [__] workout
dudes they're just
like imagine big ass workout dudes
[__] rob the bank and [__] just so
big they're like that dude that died
that is all all the memes right now or
or or um or just like uh the dude you
love the one that you always send that's
he died he's dead but the big ass
[__] workout they got like what's his
name Ronnie Co Coleman is that the guy
no that's the UFC guy whatever you know
what I'm talking about big ass [__]
dudes they look like Bradley Martin and
they're just [__] running around and
they're like they're like switching
outfits you know to so they don't get
caught but they still look like big ass
[__] and and the police are
like it's it's that guy like no he's in
a hoodie though it's not him it's just
another big guy
dude that's weird what about why did
guys get so big I'm supposed to do
Bradley Martins Park C actually I got to
text him
back why do guys get so big that's
crazy uh how big should I
get detective said at the time okay six
men middle of the night in the middle of
the
night approaching the
TR look at this four men wrong oh here
they
are uh 31 year-old Ronald bird rakee
Savage hanif Palmer and Malik
Palmer dude how big are they
though wow can't be that
big just dragging it across a
concrete
wow divided by four is
50k worst Heist hey Rob a Target hey
dude
get into [__] Bitcoin you
know look at this
here check out this forklift
[Music]
competition
no the
slowest [__]
[Music]
competition wait hold on a second bro
this is German this seems like it would
be the most American [__] of all time
and these Germans just that's the
craziest [__] you don't even know they
got forklifts in Germany and they're
[__] hauling tires this guy has them
so precariously balanced how do the [__]
they even get him up there dude how do
they get him up
there the slowest competition of all
time
dude soft is good is
cool
dude bro hey it's sold out here it's
packed this is like a burke Crusher show
what the
[__] you think this guy gets [__] for
this
I mean why do they all of a sudden have
to run and hit the button that shouldn't
have anything to do with
anything you know it's not a timed thing
I mean I guess it is a timed thing but
it's so
slow wow at least this guy looks exactly
like someone who would operate
forklift the thing I like about German
is every now and then there's a word to
English
[Music]
P every now and then there's a word in
English dude I was watching a show in
when I was in uh Europe once and they
and it was a German it was the German
German channel it's crazy that like in
in Europe they'll they'll they'll have
like a bunch of channels but then one
that's just dedicated to like German
German the language and it's like we're
in London and I would watch it because
it's funny to me and they would just be
like uh every now and then it was a
there was there were English words in
German language and the
[__] I was watching this dude that
was obviously a bodyguard or something
being interviewed and he goes I swear to
God he goes bro I mean I will never
forget this he
goes
technique and I was like
dude there's definitely words for
killing and technique in
Germany dude I I I swear to God why and
Germans get with it so anyway but they
are obviously with it because they did
the they did the um
forklift that was sent over by Rob hay
uh in our on our
patreon um one shop s shirts and hoodies
for you at Sunkissed coconut.com go to
my page if you want purchase 10-word ad
holler. christalia
um oh man I don't think anything's
funnier I don't think there's anything
funnier than like I was thinking about
um these two things a guy wait that's
not
the is this the thing
oh wow you put something here that's not
that you said the worst laugh of all
time and that's
the that's also
the forklift competition um I don't
think
that so these are the two funniest
things to me either a guy trying to
control his
emotions
uh which is why I love the Chuck
croissant videos the Chuck croissant
video and the guy and and the other on
the other podcast that I do with my
brother Lifeline the guy who had the
toothbrush the girl with the toothbrush
in his sink it seemed like he was so mad
and seething and trying not to do it but
or that is the funniest thing to me a
guy trying to hold in his emotion but
you can see the cracks to me dude I
there's only one other thing that well I
would say two other things that
are uh at that level okay a guy falling
down if it's funny
enough or a guy pretending he's not
insecure and you can See's insecure but
you could argue that that's a guy trying
to control his emotions
so no no
no here we
go here we go no and no it's today uh
Thursday oh
God am I still Rich he's on a he's on a
uh rich homie Kwan is on by the way rich
homie
Kwan but rich homie Kwan is Mr homie
Kwan is
um
uh on a live on Instagram or or
something and they say are you still
Rich am I still
Rich it's today uh Thursday slammed them
okay [__] you talk about crazy
man oh [__] that
n
oh
oh son cure dude
Rich it's today uh
Thursday didn't know what that was [__]
you stood up crazy
man thought about it thought about
moving on couldn't let it go
that I so upset dude
dude I love how black people people
always like they
translate the same language into the
same language black people would just be
like oh he
said he said like I was right there you
know dude one time I was playing in the
playground I must have said this in uh
this podcast before I was playing in the
playground dude I was so mad I was I was
walking I was actually looking bro I
must have been in sixth
grade and I was this woman this woman
this little this girl we were we were
how old are you in sixth grade this girl
was hopping across
puddles and trying to not well how do I
remember this as clear as day all right
was hopping off over puddles by herself
trying not to get splashed you know and
I was watching I I must have said this
on the podcast before and um I was
watching the uh this girl do this and
next to me people were playing like
kickball or dodgeball or some [__] it's
on the black top and uh I'm watching and
the big red ball hit
me on the head as I was watching this
this girl and it felt uh and I felt
super embarrassed that this happened
because in my head everyone s caught me
looking at this girl but I was really
just kind of in one of those I wasn't
like it wasn't like I loved her you know
what I mean like when you're in sixth
grade people be like oh you loved her
whatever I was just watching her but I
was just like looking at her I was like
if she going to make the puddles but I
was in one of those sleep days things
the ball hit my head and it was one of
those really those rubber balls that
goes thing you know and Teddy came over
Teddy Chandler stemman his real name was
dude where is he now you know what I
want I want a VH1 where are they now
about everybody in myin elementary
school that's what I want like where the
[__] is Danny Vic where's Jenny Conroy
where's quader Turner where's Sumatra I
want to know where these [__]
are you know Sumatra [__] dude one
time she stole my answer I said it
quietly next to her because the teacher
was like what's the answer and I said it
quietly and then she raised her hand and
they called on her and she said it the
answer she and I and I turned around I
said I said that out loud you got that
for me and she said you should have kept
it to
yourself never forgot it but anyway the
ball hit me in the head and Teddy came
over and he said he was dying dude I was
so mad he was laughing he said ha he he
said haha the ball said
boy and I said and I even then when I
said it I was like man I sound so
[__] insecure but I said a ball
doesn't say anything
Teddy super white you know excuse me AB
ball doesn't actually say anything Teddy
thank you very much balls make noises it
doesn't have a soul does
it is it um Thursday he said crazy
man
me when Ted me when Teddy said the
b a s secure the last one is crazy and
SC speaking of
laughs damn
it via Google is an attractive but
unintelligent or frivolous young woman
no no bro dude murder me immediately Mur
no come on dude not real I would be so
angry if my via Google is an attractive
but unintelligent or frivolous young
woman come on
dude a
velociraptor the one coming in from the
side dude get out of
here I've never been that loud in my
life no i' constantly am that loud but
that's crazy crazy
dude I did not
know dude you know what sucks having an
annoying laugh God it
sucks you got to be around that person
and your friends you can't not be their
friend because of it you know you can't
not be their friend with somebody
because you can't be you can't not be
friends with somebody because of their
laugh but dude if you're a real one you
can you got to keep that [__] circle
tight bro you got to keep that circle
tight you got it but I am all I'm a big
believer in you got to hate your friends
though you got to have some sort of
level of hate with your friends
otherwise dude you ain't
[__]
um what the [__] was also that what that
guy said wasn't funny
dude she look like jar jar Banks
um
oh god dude we talked about Kodak Black
last time let's talk about him
again okay DT Donald Trump yeah [__]
that but we a got like talk too much
about this [__] I gota ask I gotta ask
that's
fire you
got how that
happen wh why is the sound on this I
know it's popular podcast why is the
sound so bad it sounds like they're
[__] iron
lung why is this so equ hey guys get
these things hey Nori get these things
get the waffle things that you put
up it sounds like they're in a [__]
hanger it said I change my life tonight
if Donald Trump reduce my sentence sir
can hear the air conditioner only redu
his sent he po pardon you all that is
pretty cool he pardoned him for what
what a c up black do Rob [__] 2
million dimes [__] that's hard hard
he you guys what are you
saying dude was Kodak Black's mom a
creaky
door never been done before he gini get
here Gemini like his birthday three days
after my [__] and I like he be vibing
out here too right so so if Trump right
now even though he probably don't need
it if he needed a million dollars would
you give him a million doll of course
[__] didn't even know on
[Laughter]
that for how you want people
grab what he say that there having know
people and people can grab
it wow his mom was a cooky door his dad
was a dying deer
uh dude I love I love rappers man I love
how
they my favorite is beef though when
they have
beef I don't understand well I'm a
rapper [__]
it I guess wait hold
on Soulja Boy oh when does Soulja Boy
not have be remember when Soulja Boy
tried to make a video game console you
know and then it didn't work because of
course rappers are crazy bro they're
crazy for a rapper to just be like yo
you know I'm going make video games is
nuts do you know what I mean there's
nobody other people doing
that imagine like [__] Tim salmon is
just like dude [__]
PS5 do you know what I'm saying imagine
Jerry Seinfeld is like I hate playing
we I'm gonna make the Seinfeld
B you put the cartridge in
P welcome to the Sun instead of sagga it
just goes
[Music]
Pampa what is the deal
pamp bro he made a video game console
what was it called I don't even know
what was the Soulja Boy video game
console called Soulja Boy Video Game Boy
video
game
p
what's his name has beef with
um soja boy has beef with
um uh Jay Cole or
whatever big
sea soldja boy had some hits though
huh before look at this I bought the
$200 soldja boy
console that's not expensive at
all it don't matter what the [__] you
like jco you stupid [__] you see what
I'm saying [__] it don't matter what you
like [__] it don't matter if
you okay you know it does to him if you
ain't like the song at first now you
like it now who gives a [__] who is
you who the [__] is you you ain't God I
mean definitely the greatest rapper
right now you
know you know what I'm saying you ain't
nobody you a you ain't bought my album
you ain't signed me you ain't put me on
you ain't put no money in no pocket who
[__] buys albums now my pocket you
ain't do a future with me I don't know
you we ain't never met we ain't never
collabed you ain't never gave me no
game
dude let's hop in the studio and and
work [__] you what have you contributed
to my whole my life since I've been born
since to to this day what have you
contri Ed to my life and my career not
one [__]
thing what's he saying behind the be
verse a feature a follow a tweet [__] I
don't even know you I ain't never spoke
to you a dayam in my
life about
everything talking about you ain't used
to who gives a [__] what hey man explain
what happened you know worst recap
nobody never listen to J Cole from
simple you like a Jay-Z ass nobody never
listen to Jay-Z nobody never listen to
you lyrical ass nobody give a
[__] this the high skill
level what did he say to
him Bo
boom what he said on a podcast or
something was that a podcast that he
said it
on oh wow and I was kind of living a
double life I had like a rapper life
like
where what the [__] is going on here
look dirty look dirty one person on
Halloween dress up as jcole oh not the
litness
[Applause]
test not the test dude imagine going
into [__] Spirit Halloween where's
your J
coile that's a hilarious thing to
say who dressed up as soldja
boy
and how many dressed up as so boy
zero the end don't nobody want to dress
up as a dirty ass bumy Homeless looking
the end dude the
end how many people dress up as jov
Halloween how many people dress up as
Soulja Boy the
end I don't know go get my special at
chia.com how about
that
um book audio time in Atlanta at astr
Studios Astro atl.com go to my page if
you want to purchase a 10-word ad or
shout out holler.
bab
christalia oh this was great this was
just
great this was fantastic this was just
fantastic the brazenness of it is the
man
[__] shouldn't use that word but
sure developmentally disabled to think
that he is going worst
backtracking go to the Clippers where
they have kawi Leonard as the number one
option Paul George is the number two and
still Russell Westbrook there and think
that he's going to shoot 25 times listen
I didn't know what you were going to say
tonight today I'm I'm shocked this is
not going to work what what's going let
me let me apologize for using that word
I I have a a my first cousin I we just
put him to he died a few months ago a
month or two ago he was developmentally
disabled so I didn't I
didn't what if he still used the RW at
the end of it he was you know he just
said it he died we put him to late him
rest he
was we we put him in AR rest he was
[__]
dude that would have been the ultimate
this guy got fired right I hope
not a oh that's that's very kind of you
I I don't think any would kill you for
it um
dude does damn well oh it's very kind of
you I don't think anyone will kill you
for
it I don't think anyone will kill you
for it what the [__] he's going to mop
and it's not going to work well is the
man [__] really leaned into it dude
Nick it starts like this Sayang it Nick
is the
man just and then the other dude the
white dude that just
goes if I said it I'd be
fired shouldn't use that word well you
shouldn't use that word dude
developmentally disabled oh dude if I
was on that show as one of those guys
and he said that
bro I will be laughing I'm I be
laughing let me apologize for using that
word I have a first cousin who died a
few months ago he was developed me
mentally disabled we laid him to
rest you know trying to Garner
sympathy oh how about Zuckerberg
dude Tores
ACL I had a bucket handle tear uh
miniscus that's sucked enough but ACL
tear
bro these rich guys and I mean
rich
just they don't they they don't have the
right Hobbies you
know it should just be training it
should just be he should be just
casually doing
Jiu-Jitsu he's not he's training for a
fight
bro Like You Know Rich dudes are like
yeah you know one of my hobbies is
collecting boats you know it's like hey
guy take up
knitting
um yeah but
he's he's in it's crazy that Mark
Zuckerberg could probably kick my ass
not now
though that's cool it's all part of it
though I didn't like man I did youu jitu
for 6 years I was always injured I
[__] hated it until I had to get my
my
miniscus [__] repaired and then I'm
like all right I'm I'm done dude oh okay
it got me I'm done oh it got me oh it
just got me and it wasn't even when I
was doing something hard I was just
taking a step around a guy trying to get
past his guard and my my knee goes and I
go and what what the [__] and one the
guy's like so you're going to need
surgery and I was like how the [__] do
you know he was a black belt and he knew
had to go get
surgery hated it didn't want to get it
got it my leg fine now I can do [__]
five pistol squats in a row what the
[__] dude now I can do five pistol
squats in a row each leg what the [__]
even weak side what the [__] I can and
now I got a [__] other guy that came
up to me said how do you do that and I'm
like Jesus Christ and he's buff what the
[__] and he has does crazy core work but
he still can't do the pistol squats what
the [__] it's a lot about flexibility
too even though it's about strength too
it's a lot about balance what the
[__] you say a lot things about Chris
Lee can't say can't do pistol Squad
that's for
sure what's up with Cory fil in right
[Music]
here hey guy dude do you have one
eye how do you not how do you not what
do they call it the um your what do you
lose no but not peripheral you lose your
if you have only one
eye what depth perception that's what it
is dude he has no depth perception dude
that's crazy that just two eyes like
that even though they're that close
together could give you that much depth
perception you know
even though they're so close our eyes
should be like this we should be like
Hammerheads Hammerheads probably got
crazy depth perception although maybe
they can just see out each side oh how
did God [__] up when he made
Hammerheads huh that
sucks that sucks dude oh my God that
sucks Hammerheads are like Indian guys
in America you know what I mean chicks
never want to [__] him dude Hammerheads
suck
dude the way they look you know I'm
saying Indian dudes are very handsome
[__] I don't give a [__] but in
America that's just how it is dude don't
get on me get on the chicks hey chicks
[__] more Indian guys you don't want me
saying this
[Laughter]
stuff I don't care anymore I don't
care it's a [__] how Cory Felman got
hit with the [__]
mouth I mean I've done it before so
[__]
[Music]
I love
it are you shidding
me oh oh my gosh Boston oh my gosh oh my
go you know oh
[__] oh
oh dude I mean how did this guy beat
this tree down it's a
tree it's got to be like a balla
tree
dude okay it's a banana plant
still look at what this person okay one
that's not a tree that's a banana which
is kind of a plant in the same like did
it's not a banana you
know come on bro that's still good I
don't give a [__] that's fast huh oh oh
my Go I mean busting dude oh my go
busting oh my go hey dude oh my
go dude in no language is God
go oh my
gosh oh my gosh dude in zero languages
God is
GH let me look at this let me look up oh
my goh let me look up G G what g o g o s
t for
God no what is the meaning of ghost a
spiritual being angel devil Spirit
oh a holy ghost I guess it is bro wow
this guy is ahead of ahead of
everyone oh my
go dude imagine you were [__] making
love and you're about to bust and you oh
my gosh that'd be the last time you saw
that lady that's for
sure God I love when my my dogs bark too
much what this here
um two and a half man Creator Chuck Lori
and Charlie Sheen ended their 12
Feud it was it was healing you know dude
how about how Chuck Lori wrote the
teenager Ninja Turtles theme song you
know this I talked about this
here we did 170 episodes together where
it before it fell apart Lori said of
their
history um oh they met or whatever I
remember Charlie Sheen called him a
clown a stupid stupid man and hurled
anti-semitic insults in 2011 dude this
was dude Charlie Sheen was like the
first guy to get canceled no yeah at the
time the actor was struggling with his
drug and alcohol addiction I guess he's
probably better now would let him to go
to does he have
AIDS where did it go that's not a real
disease dude you can just get rid of it
now um which led him to go off on
bizarre rants about winning and using
Tiger's
blood he was eventually fired from the
hit sitcom and replaced by Ashton
Kutcher who played a billionaire
businessman who brought Charlie's house
after yeah okay so they're not in a feud
anymore that's
cool
um yeah all
right oh man 12 years falling
out I guess I have people I haven't
talked to in years um what's the [__]
oh here that that was so let's do let's
round this podcast out with
that
here we
go this was
great no no no God damn
it I don't ever want it why am I never
signed in
dude just never signed in it's
okay here we go I really wanted to prove
to you that he is clean now yes good
morning again George and he claims no
drugs right now but we did talk L this
woman is everywhere
dude every time someone's being
interviewed this woman is doing it who
even is that I swear to God also she's
been that age for 90 years she's got the
Morgan Freeman disease about his past
drug use Charlie Sheen has never been
more candid about it and makes no
excuses for it he also shared with us
some of what really happened that night
last month when heed to the hospital
after a drug filled night with million
views your anger and your hate I think
is coming off as erratic to people
passion my passion it's all okay your
passion is coming off as erratic to
people well you borrow my brain for five
seconds and just be like dude can't
handle it unplug this bastard yeah
because dude he it's actually so messed
up to look at this now cuz he's so
obviously so obviously on drugs it just
it fires in a way that is um I don't
know maybe not from this particular uh
terrestrial realm there you go anytime
you talk about terrestrial I think some
of those things that you're putting out
there are making people think
something's wrong with you that's that's
up to that has nothing to do with me
really I mean they're they're entitled
to I suppose interpret stuff um as they
must a doctor of what some are saying
that you're bipolar wow what does that
mean I guess that you know you're on two
ends of the spectrum wow and then what
what's the cure medicine make me like
them not going to happen wow didn't say
that winning I win here and I win there
now
what dude
this this was so awesome man I'm glad
he's better now cuz
this this was great I wonder what it's
like for him to watch this if I'm
bipolar aren't there moments where a guy
like crashes in like in the corner like
oh my God it's all my mom's fault shut
up shut up up stop move forward have you
had any celebrities reach out to you to
try and help you yeah like radical
people like Shawn Penn and Mel Gibson
and Colin Ferell and just radical people
and it's and they're not telling me what
to do who gave you the best piece of
advice dude oh so sideways and they're
not telling me what to do so you know if
that's where you come here do you Buck
up the wrong tree Colin frell didn't
tell me what to do also Colin frell
absolutely told him what to
do
well they didn't give me any advice and
and and within that there's great advice
just dude it's just it was just love and
so you know um just to just to see it's
often times say unknown but occasionally
you know a giant Marquee name comes
through on your caller ID and it's like
winning when was the
last dude and it's like winning dude
when he did that m
like seeing K frell's name on your phone
be like oh [__] yeah he Tech he [__]
[__] yeah dude it's not unknown dude
that is the says unknown but
occasionally you know a giant Marquee
name comes through on your caller ID and
it's like winning when was the last time
you used oh used uh I don't use I use a
blender I use a vacuum cleaner I use oh
done it a million times this is his
go-to
wow uh you know I you know household
items when was the last time I ingested
or took drugs yes when drugs such an AA
stupid um expression or term I don't
remember you like that I do not remember
why you like
that yeah a week ago two weeks ago days
ago six week I don't know I don't know
it was a couple days before the suits
rolled in and said change it change
everything we're shutting you down tell
me about the last time you took drug
last time I took drugs um I probably
took more than than than anybody could
survive you know said he didn't do it
you know about how much I don't know man
I was banging seven G rocks and
finishing them because that's how I roll
I have one speed I have one gear go how
do you love it dude that's how I am with
shoes that because I'm because I'm
me cuz I'm me I'm Different I just have
a different
Constitution heart I have a different
you know I get Tiger Blood man you don't
worry that you're going to die when you
take that many drugs Dying For Fools ow
dude wow oh
wow
wow what the [__] is this it says
Charlie Sheen and his goddesses what was
that all
about you remember
that who were they red light God damn it
ads what imagine if that happened
now I am goddesses
winning I've got one speed with my
goddesses I inject my tiger blood into
them through my
penis 24 seen here as a marijuana
magazine Covergirl and Rachel Oberlin 24
also know as Bri Olen a porn star one of
many Sheen has a shine for party we win
so radically in our underwear before our
first cup of coffee it's
scary
come on
dude we win so radically in our
underwear before our first cup of
coffee
it's
scary dude just wakes up you
know just wakes
up that is the best quote I've ever
heard in my life Ma has a shine for so
let's party we win so radically in our
underwear before our first cup of coffee
it's
scary people say it's Lonely at the Top
but I sure like the
view dude when he did it he went like
this that is so gangster dude oh that's
awesome wow man all right look that's
great uh go to chris.com get my special
go now thanks for watching and uh my
special is available now it is an hour
and 10 minutes or something like that
and uh like And subscribe here we love
it and um thank you everyone for
watching if you have watched it and then
also uh I'm going to be in Fort Meers
and Orlando and also um what do you call
it Baltimore and Detroit no not Detroit
or that uh uh uh Richmond is what I
meant to say and trendon that's it for
YouTube if you want the end uh of the
episode of the rest of the episode I
should say the uncut version without ads
uh go to uh patreon.com christalia and
that's it it's six bucks you get all the
extended episodes and you also get all
the rest of the episodes that only we
can do one EP we do one extra episode a
month so you can go get them all right
now for six bucks go patreon.com Christa
thank
[Music]
you
he